hi i'm wayne this is emily and we're
just going to show you how to milk a cow
we've been out here about seven years
and
we're really bad when we started we're
not experts so i'd love it if you know
more than us you could put in the
comments
some tips on how to milk but basically
we're gonna give it a go we've got some
green clover here because she loves that
as a treat and a bit of loosen for after
we're finished
so
we'll give her a little treat before she
starts
just to make sure she comes up and is
ready for the milking so we don't have
to go and get her
hello jet fighter how are you today hey
how are you
i just put this rope around her neck
as a way of saying
boy
sit swampy sit phoebe
not good having the dogs too close
swampy back
go back sit good boy sit
so this rope is just the way of saying
to her when you got this rope around
your neck stands still don't move i'm
trying to train her can you move back a
bit lauren because she's interested in
you that's better
beautiful what's this camera
you you like the camera do you jet
fighter
so the first little bit's just relaxing
us so
give a little scratch and
um
rub down with a brush but the dogs got
our brush a couple of days ago so we
don't have it
and you you want a milk or holder you
hold it today
in the past i've tied this to a star
post
and that keeps her still
but i'm trying to train jet fighter to
stand still with no post so that we can
just milk her
without tying her up so
she hasn't learned it yet but that's the
aim
when you're giving her a rub down it's
good to give her a rub under her tummy
and down near her utter just so that she
starts getting
used to it
so she had her first car just there
about two weeks ago so
she hasn't been milked before two weeks
so she's still learning
when you first start to milk her
um don't just go and grab the teeth
because i think they're a little bit
ticklish so if i just go and grab the
teeth from nowhere
oh she's not going to do it she might
kick so don't just do that sort of work
your way around make it feel comfortable
and then down to it
is a better way when you're starting
we don't let her eat at all from the
grass while we're melting just as a way
of um
so she doesn't move around
and she loves a big scratch around her
ears and on a hairy bit
all this is just part of relaxing ara
and
if she gets the point of chewing a cud
she's really relaxed that's good
okay jet fighter i'm gonna milk you now
thank you
so
first thing is this is
fairly warm water
actually this is a bit too warm today
just gonna wipe her uttering teeth clean
thank you jet fighter
this is just in case there's any dirt
she's been sleeping on it oh hey
that fighter see how she flicked me
before she
kicks with her foot
that's just the flicks the way of saying
hey i don't like that i've got to listen
to her tail flicks
see how there's just a bit of
a bit of gut comes off there
i like to give it a good
a good clean because
we don't pass dry some milk we just
drink it raw
so you want this all nice and clean
so no hit bits of hair and things fall
in
great
good girl
next thing
so dry it off
draw my hands
it's with another old nappy
good girl jet fighter
right now
people use various things on the teats
to moisturize them
we use some
coconut oil
so the coconut oil has been sitting in
the hot water
that that melts it
and
i just put a bit on each teat
so coconut oil is also a mild
antifungal antibacterial kind of thing
so
it does stop infections a little bit so
it's
really good
also
the first thing and i do it now before i
get the bucket is that first bit of milk
in each tea you just squirt out onto the
ground
because if there are any
bits of bacteria or yucky
sitting in the end of the teat
you don't want that in your milk
so a couple of squirts from each tape
i'm a bit of a
i like to do this too i do a couple of
squirts in the bucket
give it a little rinse out
don't have to do that
this bucket's been sterilized with
boiling water and then we start milking
so
bucket there what she may do
is
try and put this foot forward and if she
does it'll kick that bucket so i'm ready
to grab the bucket and hold her foot if
she does do that
and emily's gonna sing because
she loves singing all the cows love
singing and they
relax more so
you're gonna sing there emily
beautiful
and so
there's two ways of milking one is you
grab the top
and then squeeze it out
like you grab the top and then squeeze
it out like that
but i the other way is just stripping it
and because her teeth are short i think
stripping's better
so
what you don't want is the milk from
here getting pushed back up into the
udder so the worst thing is just
squeezing it because if you squeeze it
you might be actually pushing the
milk up way through a one-way valve and
plus if there's any bacteria
in the right in the end of the teat you
might be pushing that up into the really
clean udder so you always go down that's
why when you're starting stripping it's
almost impossible to go
backwards when you're stripping whereas
if you're doing this way if you ex if
you haven't gripped it
hard enough there and then you squeeze
this one it might squeeze it back up so
if you're starting the stripping is good
as i'm starting i'm just like i'll do
the front two teats i'll try the back
teeth there
and the other back teeth
right so i'm feeling that
these front two feel
fairly empty so they're the ones the
calf probably drank off
this back one's really full
so i'm going to make sure that i'm
always milking from that back one
because it's going to
right and then you just
milk
how's she going up there emily
she's chewing a card not yet
but she's um getting there
some little tips i think they like it
with if you go in with your head like
this and
just rest on them don't know why
i find the most comfortable way to sit
is just crouching like this actually but
some people like a stool
um
a little craft over there having a
nibble on the listen
oh
the teats don't all squirt down so if i
just squirt this one it sort of goes
back so that means i have to sort of
point it down so
if i pull it this way it'll point down
this this teat
it does pretty right direction
this back teeth
it's going to squirt way out there so i
have to pull it this way as i'm milking
so that it goes into the bucket so you
just sort of if the teeth are squirting
that way you milk it this way see so the
bottom's
facing the right way you work that out
now if you have little tips for me
i'd love it because we've only learnt
out of books and from youtube
so
uh
there you go i'm jet fighter
this is lovely today
hello
how you doing
how are you today jet fighter this is
lovely milk
she's staying pretty still today
sometimes you can feel her weight shift
forward which means she's going to take
a step which isn't good and you've got
to sort of
be ready to move the bucket
see that there how i had to move the
bucket away and keep her leg back
no jet fighter that's not very nice okay
no kicking please
when she does kick i try and go back to
milking in exactly the same way that i
was on the same teats
just so that she learns if she kicks she
doesn't get any change
otherwise
she'll get trained to kick
to teach me to move
so
whatever i was doing when she kicked
unless it was particularly hurting her
i'd go straight back to doing it
what's that flip about
so see the milk there that's about oh
what are you doing there jet fighter no
clicking please
about a quarter of a bucket so far so
we're a quarter of the
way through
so
that's
there you go emily
um
so
hey jet fighter
was that about jet fighter
it's not very good
thank you
i've had a few squirts here where i've
got milk on my finger like that
see
what i hold your finger up
if your fingers down you get milk on it
now because i've got milk on it some of
the oils wiped off
it's actually getting a bit dry up here
so
i'm gonna put a bit more oil on
hello getting a bit more oil
um
this teat's got a bit of a cut
on the exact other side of it
so when you've got a cut you sort of got
to try and get it so that
you're not squeezing on the cut
what's happening jet fighter
oh she's interested in the bucket
back please
leg back come on hey
good girl
you don't go wandering off like that
you got a bit of a boogie in your nose
today
so
this
hey
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
me
um
good morning
[Music]
head back emily
thank you
just hold her head
we're basically trying to train her to
sit there patiently and not eat and not
move so
the reason we have two people is because
um she's only been milking two weeks so
she's not trained i would like to get to
the point where i come down and milk her
without emily or emily milton without me
and she just stands there don't know if
that'll work but
so
what's that about i don't know thank you
mmm
so
emily
foreign
[Music]
my
there's only two warning kicks there and
then
[Music]
this front teeth
it's just about running out
very central
see how it's getting thinner
so that others nearly empty
there it's got none left
see that
so you're good it's good to strip it dry
like that
so that
well it's not so important when there's
a calf on but
especially if there's no calf and you
want to get them all dry like that so
there's no milk left so that there's
less chance of mastitis that other front
ones nearly
finished too
yeah it's finished
so that one's finished not much there if
you rub that other you might get a
little bit more milk down
not much
great
now it's just the back two
oh
that was flickers because i'm
back on this sore one with the cut on it
now this is just milking this back one
only one left
so
we finished
um
[Music]
hey
we're nearly finished but not quite
thanks jet fighter
she's ready to go
nearly finished their jet fighter
oh this one's got a cut on it
can you see there
yeah
yeah calf cutter so i want to make sure
that i do empty this one out
because i've found that if there is one
that's gonna
good they're all finished now
all empty
great there we go a nice big
bucket of milk
put our
coconut milk away
now
i like to put that away before the dogs
get it
okay
good girl thank you for your milk today
that's got a little bit of
dolomite and mineral mix in there
i think it has
sulfur selenium magnesium zinc bloody
black just a really basic
trace mineral mix to make sure she gets
what she needs
okay there you go
beautiful milk to have
iced coffees and
yogurt and cream and coffee and
thank you jet fighter good job
good job
good girl hey
yeah you're a good girl
thank you for your milk today
don't forget if you've got any tips
on what we're doing wrong and how we
could make the milking better
give us a little comment